Hi.
I'm Eiji, and I'm a
developer advocate at Google.
Today, I'm going to give you
an overview of Web Components.
Web Components are a set
of emerging standards that
changes the way you
develop web apps entirely.
They will enable you to
build and reuse UI components
when building web applications.
Let's take a look at how you
might build a UI element today
and how that process
can be improved
by using Web Components.
Here is a nice looking chart.
How would you build this using
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript?
It must be a bit of work if
you create this from scratch.
To help us build
our chart, we can
use the Google
Visualization API.
First, load the Google
JavaScript Library
to use the API.
Then, add the div tag onto
the body as a placeholder.
Now, using JavaScript
initialize the library
by loading Visualization API.
Then, set the values and
the options at callback.
Finally, specify the DOM element
to upend the chart graphic.
OK.
Now, let's dive into
the Web Components
approach and see
how that drastically
changes the way
you build a chart.
With Web Components, the
first thing you should do
is to import Google
Chart Component.
To enable unsupported
browsers to work,
you will also need to
load an open source
polyfill called platform.js.
Then add the Google Chart tag
and fill in the attributes
as you wish.
And done.
Did you notice the difference
between those two approaches?
Yes.
The first one was
imperative using JavaScript.
The second one was
declarative using HTML tag.
The declarative approach
might look easier to handle,
but the biggest difference
here is not easy or difficult.
It is an underlying knowledge
required for the developer
to use those APIs.
In the original example, the
first thing you have to do
is to understand how Google
JavaScript Library works.
Then, you can learn how to
use the APIs to control it.
On the other hand, the
Web Components approach
uses DOM APIs, which most
of the web developers
are already familiar with.
So you can just
start by learning
how to use attributes and APIs.
The difference seems subtle,
but you'll notice the benefit
when you work with
other UI libraries.
For example, jQuery UI,
Bootstrap, Closure Libraries,
et cetera, all
use different approaches,
so you will have to learn
them before you actually
start using them.
There are other benefits of
using Web Components, as well.
Let's take a look
at them one by one.
Scoped.
Since Web Components have
scoped styles and markup,
imported components
won't harm any other part
of your web page.
In the existing
libraries, there are
cases where you have same class
names or IDs that potentially
overlap with the
ones in the library.
With Web Components,
all markups and CSS
are scoped to the element.
This mean the CSS bundled
with the component
will not leak out to
affect the parent document.
And it also prevents
the parent document
from accidentally
styling the component.
Reusable.
Because Web Components
are scoped and decoupled
with other parts
of your web page,
you can use the same component
in the other part of your web
page or even on
the other website.
Furthermore, you can
share the element
with the community
as open source
so that anyone can take
advantage of your work.
Isolation.
Because Web
Components are scoped,
you can decouple
development of UI components
from main functionality.
Developers are able
to independently work
on UI components without
needing to worry or be
aware of the implementation
details of other parts
on the page.
Note that maintaining
those components
is much easier because
of isolation as well.
OK.
Web Components sounds
like a great solution
for serving or
using UI components.
So how can we actually
build our own component?
Web Components consists of four
core technologies-- templates,
Shadow DOM, Custom
Elements, and HTML Imports.
Let me briefly describe
what they are like.
Templates allow you to
define inert boilerplates
for repeatedly used
markup inside your HTML.
Because the content of
the template is inert,
it will not request
images or run scripts
until it is sent
out onto the page.
Shadow DOM allows you to
associate scoped HTML markup
and CSS with an
existing DOM element.
Since Shadow DOM
is encapsulated,
the style won't affect
anything outside of it.
Custom elements allows
you to define and register
a custom HTML element as if
it were a native element.
HTML Imports allow you to
load multiple resources,
such as JavaScript, CSS,
and additional HTML files
by loading a single HTML.
Combining all those technologies
will look something like this.
First, prepare a HTML file that
is separate from main HTML.
Define and register
a custom element.
Associate Shadow DOM onto it.
Use templates to provide
contents of the Shadow DOM.
Finally, import the component
HTML file using HTML Import.
Now you have the basic
idea of Web Components.
I'm going to post a series of
videos about Web Components
features so you can
learn how to use them.
In the meantime, documents
and resources listed here
will help you learn more
about Web Components,
so please check them out.
All right.
Thank you for watching.
See you in the next episode.